hey guys so Matt Barnes and Stephen
Jackson are former NBA players with a
combined 100 million dollars in career
earnings and now they host the all this
smoke podcast which is one of the
largest Sports podcasts and they've had
guests like Kobe Bryant Steph Curry
Kevin Hart Shaq and many more in this
episode we talk about the overwhelming
amount of money in the sports industry
and how unfortunately a lot of it goes
to waste so if you're interested in
episodes just like this make sure to
subscribe because we post a brand new
video every single week so first off you
guys may notice we're using two
different size mic stands here because
these are the biggest guests we've ever
had on the podcast the tallest the
tallest guys we've ever had on the
podcast it's an honor we have Matt
Barnes and Stephen Jackson former NBA
players according to Google it says you
guys have a combined earning of over 100
million dollars they must be lying is
that is that true that's what that's
what Google says yeah a lot of money
yeah maybe I didn't know it was that
much
I saw 65 and 30
I mean that is absolutely incredible and
now you guys have a massive podcast all
the smoke it's one of the biggest Sports
broadcasts out there right now and uh
it's an honor to have you guys here so
much for coming thanks for having us so
we got to talk a little bit about your
back story and how you got started in
this how you guys met and a little bit
about the business aspect of of coming
up in the uh uh Jack and I met Jack got
traded from Indiana Golden State where I
was at the time and during the 2006-2007
season
um like in the January February
instantly you know we just bonded uh and
made NBA history
during that season with the uh you know
being the first number eight seed in the
seven game series ever be the number one
seed the very next season my mom died
from cancer like really fast within a
month and Jack was one of the one one of
the main guys that just took time away
from the team and Charlie back and forth
to see my mom but every single day I was
there Jack brought me food brought me
weed came and just sat and talked
sometimes we didn't say nothing you know
he was just there for me and that went
from
teammates to to a real life brother and
um fast forward and we both had 14-year
careers
and went into the media space uh mess
around with Fox and ESPN and we were
getting a lot of positive feedback we
were at my house in the bay one time and
kicking back and I was just like
do a podcast he's like what's the
podcast I was like I don't know but I
don't know what people are doing it Joe
Rogan like I know we can drink smoke and
cuss and we couldn't do that on our
other platforms so um
let's do it and you know now we're about
going on three years now and sports
podcast of the year and uh it's just
been a great experience and learning
experience at the same time shout out
Danielle his sister my sister came up
with the name yeah great name I'm
curious did you always think you would
play basketball I think you started with
that I was a football guy yeah I was uh
I was die hard football
um picked up basketball because I kept
getting taller but I knew somehow
someway one of those two sports were
going to be my profession and you know
growing up in a household in an
environment of drugs abuse violence
um I just knew that my path was always
going to be different so although I saw
everything you know I was someone who
started smoking we did about 14 but that
was about as deep as I went into it uh I
was just really locked in on Sport and
how about you Stephen always basketball
uh I think yeah it was always basketball
my city and my parents my family saw
something in me that I didn't know I had
at a young age and um they put a
basketball in my hand obviously my
family they knew I had something
different and they they kept me around
and they kept me out of trouble like I
said they seen something in me that I
didn't even know I had as you know what
age is that how old are you so it
started at five for me when I was five
years old I played in the game at the
YMCA score was 44-40 and I had 42 hour
points at five and you always been a
ball hog yeah I always been a ball hog
and around that time everybody's like
hold up this kid really has something
from then on my city treated me like I
was an NBA Prospect and it worked out
that way so there was like a time where
you realized okay I could do this for a
living this is you know my most likely
career yeah I mean yeah because you know
I fell in love with it and I knew I was
good at a young age and you know playing
basketball once you fall in love with
the game you start to fall in love with
NBA and the players in the NBA and you
start to have idols and you start to Pat
in your game after players and um and I
started that like any other kid that
played basketball nobody knew it would
get to the NBA you know I ended up going
out of high school but um like I said
people around me my High School coaches
my parents they knew that I was on my
way there but I didn't see what's it
like getting a deal and getting your
first you know bonus how do you know
where that money went you guys were GQ
my first million I've seen it it's
reenact a little bit that's what you
guys did with your first time like what
was the first signing check how what's
the process like how do they how do they
find it I'm gonna give you this person
I'm gonna give you two my first I signed
with the Phoenix Suns and they gave me a
check for twenty five thousand dollars
cash this was in 97. blew it all in one
day I blew it all in one day me and Mike
Bibby his sister my little brother went
to the mall and bought everything we
could find I think when I got back to
the house I probably had like maybe four
or five thousand dollars damn it blew it
all in the mall that was my first check
but I got when I signed my six year deal
with the Pacers uh personally I did was
brought my mom and my grandmother house
yeah my first you know I was someone a
guy that came in on minimum deals you
know what I mean so my deals were 300
400 500 000 you know the first few years
and to be honest with you at the end of
every summer I was broke you know
because you know financial literacy is
something that's talked about often now
but you think late 90s early 2000s it
wasn't talked about you know we talked
about houses cars jewelry women
everything but you know how to save what
we're all working for so
um with no background I came from Food
Stamps and drugs so I didn't really have
any kind of representation they showed
me you know okay we'll put this away and
save this and do this invest this so
like Jack said when he came in it went
out even faster so it took me about
maybe maybe going into year four or five
maybe to really start understanding okay
I'm gonna get this amount and put this
aside
um I never really made any you know huge
you know I got my mom and dad cars I
never really made I got myself a house
but yeah so my first I really didn't go
cry I wasn't a jewelry guy
um you know like I said I bought a house
bought my mom and dad some cars and that
was kind of you know kind of
understanding like I have money but I
don't have a ton of money you know what
I mean so that's kind of see if we can
space this up and when did the money
really start rolling in from the pro
basketball careers those first couple
years I won a championship with the
Spurs in O3 I was expecting to get paid
after that year and I didn't they paid
somebody else so I had to go to the
Atlanta Hawks for the minimum and play
again just to prove myself to get paid
so um and I got paid that following year
in uh in Indiana but it was a blessing
but like he said it took me six about
six years in my career to understand how
to even think about generational wealth
like when we was growing up that word
never even came around nobody in my
family ever thought about saying
generational wealth right so it took me
being around people and having financial
advisors six seven years in my career to
start thinking about saving for a rainy
day yeah and I think my my light turned
on when I started having kids so I came
in the league at like 21 I had twins at
28 so probably seven eight years in
that's where I realized okay you know
there's got to be a future here although
I hope my kids are you know great at
whatever they do and they get
scholarships just in case you know so it
started being less about me and more
about obviously my kids after that and
that's what kind of turned the light on
for me so when you were playing what was
the schedule like day to day like how
much training were you putting in how
much were you were you putting into like
Diet to exercise different and all that
uh it's different for everybody
um and again when we first came in the
game there wasn't there wasn't that kind
of talk like it's regular now you know
what I mean like during the summer time
we play we got basketball and smoke weed
like that was really that's our workout
how every like I'd say majority of the
NBA was and not till you know I was
lucky enough to play until 2017 and you
know it's to me it probably started
changing around 12 or 13 where diet was
important and you know all these other
nuances of the game started coming in to
kind of preserve your career but like I
said we're not that we're old school but
almost like you know kind of the old
school as far as it was basketball and
weave for us that was it wasn't weight
training it wasn't training all the time
it was just it just wasn't what it was
at the time and so it's so far Advanced
now where I have kids that are you know
13 and they're training you know three
to four times a week now and that was
really more than I was training when I
first got in the NBA how important do
you think all those tangential exercises
practices make you at basketball how
much does that improve your game is it
extreme really important it works I mean
you you know anything you put hard work
in until you're gonna get something out
of it and especially with basketball I
mean that's why Kobe was in the time
that's why LeBron's so great you want to
spend a million dollars on his body a
year just to be great a million dollars
on his body that's a bargain maintenance
yeah what does that even mean just
maintenance he has right fools the right
trainers you know right there all year
round numbers I just eaten right during
the season sure you get like massages
chiropractors
you know he's going into year 20 and
he's been great his entire career you
know a lot of we've seen a lot of great
players play for a long time but have we
ever seen someone play at the level that
LeBron has been able to play for so long
and obviously that's to what he does off
the court and his upkeep
um so I mean I think it's very
beneficial obviously again it wasn't
something that we were major into really
toward the end of my career but um you
know as like I said being a father of
twin boys or teenagers now and I'm
coaching them I could like I didn't work
out for the NBA until I got to the NBA
that sounds crazy but I just didn't like
now my kids are training and I can see
the drastic improvement week by week
month by month year by year I'm just
like man I wish I would have had this
when I was younger because training camp
I didn't yeah I didn't have that and I
still made the league and played 14
years I couldn't imagine if this was
something like my parents put me here
and I knew what I was going to do when I
had a regimen and all this kind of [ __ ]
it would have been a whole nother play
uh you know experience for me I think so
at what point in your guys's career
could you call yourself like an actual
liquid millionaire and I like I said
like a year after I signed my big deal
around seven years when I actually went
through that first year of that season
and able to see you know a million
dollars in my bank account saved that
was the first time I ever saved a
million dollars once I was able to put
that away and no I had to touch it and I
would still have checks and stuff coming
in
I was able to say that yeah it don't
mean yeah what was that like for you to
see though uh it's a gift and the curse
because you feel good but then you got
people doing this now oh no I'm saying
and and that that's always the sad part
because there's a lot of people that
feel they're entitled now those same
people that was telling you you go ahead
and you do this you know what I'm saying
but we didn't make it off told you souls
and keep going like uh like uh the
Russell say we made it off hard work and
and just just meant for us to be here
but you know that's that's the sad part
about it you know you know how people
feel like they're entitled to your money
you gotta you know you you take care of
a village you know if you're the one
that's fortunate enough to make it and
the hardest thing to do is you know be
able to tell people no you know really
the hardest thing to do is you know tell
family no it's tough and I mean I can
tell I have friends that I've helped and
they're all appreciative but I've never
had a problem be like okay
good but you know obviously when you
have to tell your family no that's a
different level and I think all people
coming into money not just athletes have
to understand that because again
everyone feels like they're entitled to
you know if they've been around the
whole time they feel like they're
entitled so being able to tell people no
is is big but same thing six seven years
into the game
um and being able to save it and see it
you know was important but again I still
didn't have a plan with it you know what
I mean so although I saw it I spent it I
said it once and I'll say it again
Henson razors have given me the cleanest
and smoothest shave I've ever had in my
entire life and since a family-run
Aerospace machine shop that has brought
Precision Engineering to razors the
razors have a precisely built handle
that securely holds the blade this firm
grip on the blade combined with an
extremely precise extension means you'll
get not only a safer but a cleaner and
closer shave and if you're interested in
shaving money you're only going to spend
between three and five dollars a year
which is way less than all of those
other subscription Services no
subscriptions no proprietary blades and
no planned obsolescence only having to
replace an inexpensive blade and not the
whole cartridge or in some case is the
entire razor just makes sense I
personally hate the idea of waste and
when you combine that with the money you
save with Henson it's truly unmatched
plus it's fully metal and uses standard
dual Edge blades that you could buy
practically anywhere seriously guys
we're going off script here but since
they sent us the razors that's literally
all I've used to shave and I gotta say
it is the cleanest shave I've ever had
in my entire life when I run it over my
neck it doesn't even feel like I'm
shaving it just somehow the hair just
disappears it's time to say notice
subscriptions and yes to a razor that'll
last you a lifetime so visit
hensonshaving.com iced coffee to pick
the razor for you and use code iced
coffee and you'll get two years worth of
blades for free with your razor just
make sure to add them to your cart
that's 100 free blades when you visit
hensonshaving.com iced coffee and use
code iced coffee at checkout thank you
so much Henson and back to the podcast
often does that come up that family or
close friends ask for money
um
man it's been happening since I was late
I've been at your house yeah you know
I'm actually kind of short on some cats
is it like directly asking like hey man
I'm really struggling to make rent this
month can I please just happen with
everyone it might be a lot it might be
like everyone has their own angles some
people go right to it text you like hey
can I have some money some people ask
how your day is going first like when
people call you Thursday and actually
and just to know because they go
actually Monday so again everyone has
their methods in in rhyme and reason and
asking and you know some people you say
yes to and some people I just you know I
ain't got it even if I do have it
because I just don't feel like giving it
to you so you're saying they'll try to
Buddy up to you ahead of time and then
be able to act like a week later think
like oh by the way man they plant the
seed last week to ask us this week and
then it's a different situation when you
grow up around a lot of guys that you
know that didn't make it and and didn't
restate potential so the first thing
they're going to say is oh man you
changed yeah I did honestly that's why I
was broke with you I ain't broke no more
I worked hard and got and got myself
some money put my family in a different
positions so and and they try to use
that against you as like a trip yeah
like a guilt trip like you changed
you're right I did change I worked hard
and I changed to get myself out of
better position but that's stuff you
have to deal with in this in the uh
areas we come from you have to grow some
tough skin because everybody will feel
like they're entitled uh to what you
work for yeah no this may be a little
nosy but is there like a specific
example that you guys like think of when
you think of people asking for money
maybe it was like your assistant coaches
like bro
I'm ready
I want to hear it I had um a church I
was uh part-time Muslim I was a
Christian and my grandmother grandfather
basically ran to church my whole life so
I grew up in a church
and as they got older they couldn't run
a church so they brought in another
Pastor from from outside to run our
church well he ended up stealing money
and kicking my grandmother grandfather
to church where the church was in debt
all kind of stuff when I first made it
made it this guy told my mom I had a
vision I wanna I want you I want you and
uh Stevie to call me Stevie I want you
and Stevie to meet me over here at the
store at this abandoned store how to
Vision I want to tell you about my
vision you fell for it too no my mom did
oh no I was there Roy D I was rolling up
she was like come around come over here
and uh
she's like come over here what yeah well
come back to that I want you got to come
so well maybe go and see what Reverend
Washington
we get to the place he tells my mom he
had a vision that God told him to for me
to give him a million dollars to turn
this uh uh broken down Safeway grocery
store into a church
and what kind of [ __ ] was that yeah
[Music]
no beer money for you to build a church
that I ain't gonna never go to but it
worked it did not work okay no he didn't
get a dime my mama cursed him out all
that okay I haven't talked to him since
why did she curse him out what happened
there because right you to him right
right but she didn't think it was that
oh she didn't think he was doing it
going that far would ask for a million
dollars okay 15 20 help the community
something like that a million lost your
rabbits
uh we glanced over the selling crack
Parts what that's so crazy hearing that
come from your mouth what
I mean
yeah
I was around it you know what I mean my
guy John Johnson rest in peace he used
to take care of me so there's a lot of
things I used to do for him involving
that to make money yeah you know what I
mean and I was no different from
everybody else in my neighborhood
everybody did that so I was I was just
blessed to have basketball to get away
from it for sure yeah and uh that was
the best that's the biggest blessing
yeah what age was that at about uh
probably from
14 18 19. 14 yeah
how much were you making doing that it
depends
um I wasn't the actual Source I was
doing different things so I can you were
like 300 200 like that was like good
money I mean that was I was 14 15 years
old 200 go a long way oh man once you
get an ounce a week for fifty dollars
wow that's gonna last the rest of the
week and buy some pizza buy some [ __ ]
and then go buy some shoes yeah and I
was getting two 300 like almost every
day I was helping my mom with groceries
my mom worked from six in the morning to
six at night so I've never seen her she
was at school when she was at you know
when she was home sleeping we come home
from school she going to work so I never
seen my mom did I ever scare you did you
ever almost get caught you don't think
about being scared you think you
surviving
so that's just a way of life that's just
the way of life yeah bubble where that's
just normal yeah I get that
now you mentioned earlier about the
people who don't live up to their full
potential and don't make it have you
noticed anything within them that maybe
they don't have a certain quality or
whether it was persistence or anything
that got in the way that you feel maybe
that's a lot of them on social media
right now and I think the thing is with
them is that they they instead of
working and putting the work in they
want to say why him and not me yeah you
know what I mean it's a whole bunch of
people saying that but they don't know
what you went through to get where you
at for sure right so that's that's
that's the biggest thing people like why
him and not me why he made it we did we
did the same things well you don't know
what I went through to get here right
and that's just the biggest thing
everybody like I said feel entitlement
entitlement and it takes a lot of luck
you know a lot a lot of guys coming up
that were better just as good and just
you know made a wrong turn along the
path you know and that's why you know I
think my family and friends were I had
friends die from overdoses and getting
shot at and all kinds of other things
but like I said although I was amongst
that and in that you know I was able to
stay on that path knowing that you know
what my ultimate goal was and you know
what the people around me wanted for me
too so you know along with what he said
it just takes it takes a lot of luck man
you know like there's only been 5 000
NBA players in the history of the game
300 something jobs a year yeah 400 yeah
400 jobs I would have thought it'd be
like 30 000. oh there's only like 400
jobs each season you know what I mean
and so you know the turnover you know
you're probably bringing in 100 120 new
guys every season and losing you know
losing that many as well so it's just
that a lot of luck goes with it you know
the average career is two or three years
you know what I mean so to get past that
and play double digit years and and be
able to win it was you know it was uh
obviously a lot of God a lot of hard
work but a lot of luck best athletes are
in prison
I'm just keeping it real no let's hear
it the best basketball players the best
football players are in prison so if you
talk to any athlete from NFL to baseball
to to about basketball they get they got
they know somebody yeah who was the
coolest athlete they've ever seen thing
growing up in my line that's in jail
right now as any athlete think I'm like
yeah I got a guy man who I grew up with
he in jail right now but I'm telling you
he's supposed to be in the league and
every guy going to say that and we all
grew up with guys like that that made
one bad decision yeah you know what I'm
saying they ended up in jail the rest of
their life how does that mindset affect
you today having that sort of uh you
know growing up in that sort of
environment does that stick with you or
are you humble yeah I'm not going back
yeah I'm not making no mistakes I'm
where we at right now being able to be
in this space with showtime and Madness
podcast like
be morons to play ourselves off this
spot you know what I mean we talk about
it all the time we not Hall of Famers
right we are the guys that we are your
favorite player favorite player right
and when we were guys that did the Dirty
Work in the game we're NBA champions but
we're not Hall and famous normally when
you when you retire
Hall of Famers and all-stars guys that
was on the commercials get the jobs and
and the stuff that we are doing right
now you know what I mean but the roads
have reversed because we are more
uh reachable and touchable than those
actual stars like we are the guys that
hang out I hang out at the Arenas and
talk to everybody and sign all
autographs so with doing that it's
paying us back you know we we had this
position now for a reason because we
always treated people with respect and
we treated everybody how we wanted to be
treated so that's how it works for us
man I mean yeah I mean I just think
obviously you know understanding where
you're coming from is always important
but the goal is to make it out yeah and
and you know continue to elevate and you
know that's what we've been able to do
um you know get the odds are the odds
were stacked against us and we were able
to get out and and have a you know
a long career and then you know for us
to be able to make the splash we've made
post career
um in in several different spaces
it's been it's been dope you know what I
mean but again to always understand
where you came from and like Jack said
not wanting to go back yeah no that's
the goal is you know obviously if we're
going to go back you're going to help
you're not going back to live on the
level you came from now where do you
learn how to get the skills in terms of
of managing your money investing it
making sure you're spending an
appropriate amount the experience was
the best teachers right I mean being
being broke in the summertime you know
not having seeing my family not having I
know I'm making money all those
situations experience is the best
teacher and I had to go through it to
understand how to save to want to save
you know to to to be able to be a crutch
on my family like seeing them not have
that made me focus on being able to be
the breadwinner be the backbone of my
family so knowing that where we come
from it's imperative that I'd be the
best protecting provider that I can be
and it starts with me making better
decisions and you know just for you know
like again getting coming from you know
food stamps and and and and not really
having no money
um actually having money even if you
have a a you know a situation in place
but eventually financial advisor agent
everything you never had nothing I don't
there's nothing No One's Gonna Be able
to tell me to say I can't spend my money
you know what I mean so until you get to
a point where you understand it's
important to say and you you really want
to save and I think that's what happens
with a lot of athletes is you know a lot
of people have you know the framework in
in place but it's just like man we never
had and like Jack said my family needs
this I want this I work my hard you know
I want to reward myself for this so it's
just like until you get in your mind
that okay there's a reason for me it was
kids there's a reason I need to start
saving or okay I'm old enough now I want
to start saving
um you know hopefully that's when the
light comes on and then that's when you
kind of start after understanding and
pull back and maybe change habits that
you've been accustomed to for a long
time but this understanding this is a
marathon not a Sprint I mean and I think
when I first got money it was a Sprint I
said that [ __ ] you know went out faster
than it came in so just being older and
you know you get wiser with age and I
think that's when it kind of kicks in
for people it's interesting that the the
switch flipped for both of you guys with
responsibility to other people like
financial responsibility to your kids or
to your family that was the main driving
factor for you guys be like okay gotta
start saving because I got to provide
and protect and I find that really
interesting that it wasn't necessarily
for yourself you know what I mean you're
like you know you may realize in the
summer like you said you have no money
and you're like oh my gosh like you know
I can't go to the fancy restaurant with
all my my teammates because I don't want
to buy it or something but it wasn't
that it was just responsibility to other
people yeah well I mean I just always
feel this responsibility when you come
from nothing you know what I mean
because there are although there's a lot
of clingers there are a lot of people
that really helped you get to where
you're getting to you know what I mean
like you're like okay well damn you know
he trained me all those years for free
or you know my mom and dad said so and
so or this guy did you know I mean so
you always have you know does this kind
of situations so we're always going to
feel not indebted but just like okay I
got it you're gonna have it too right
way so again until you kind of just
figure out what that balance is if
you're able to do it for a long time
that's great but if you have to scale
back those are the tough conversations
you have to have with people
understanding okay
you know the money's not coming in the
way it used to be coming in so I'm gonna
have to scale back that means you know
your lifestyle is going to have to scale
back so it's a lot and that that's a lot
of again a lot of athletes or musicians
or you know people uh have to deal with
that and you know everyone deals with a
difference there's this segment I
remember on this this thing on YouTube I
forget what channel it is but it's like
the best and worst purchases that people
make it'd be kind of fun if you guys
recollected on the best purchase maybe
or every piece of joy every piece of
jewelry I bought is the worst purchase
I've ever what about now what about what
you're wearing the worst I still buy it
it's the worst person I've ever had I
mean yeah I'm not I'm not the guy I
don't have 10 cars I got two cars
whatever cars you have I have a I have a
Range Rover and a Mercedes and my wife
has a Range Rover um we're not into cars
and we don't have houses everywhere so
every every now and then I buy myself a
piece of jewelry which I'm you know
that's that's my thing but the dumbest
thing to do of anybody listening it's
not really uh obviously house you know
to me I'm not really
um yeah I mean house and again just a
stability you know when you have to
bounce around and move and live with
family and all that kind of [ __ ] live
with friends like houses important so
obviously that's you know that that
that's when I was able to buy my first
house that was like okay dope
um worst
I wouldn't say it was first purchase
because again I'm not someone that's
crazy with buying dumb [ __ ] it was just
always buying everything for everybody
you know we're going to dinner I'm
always paying for if we're going on
vacation I'm paying for it so I just
think just always feeling like again
like I said early obligated to take care
of people because they don't have it I
think I waste a lot of money doing that
I'm really curious are finances and the
payments getting better for athletes
over time are they getting worse do you
think you maybe had a better deal back
then than the new athletes money is
resources yeah money is crazier than
it's ever been you know these new TV
deals the deals are crazy now but deals
are gonna get even crazier so I mean
obviously and that kind of just comes
with the you know as the game continues
to evolve you know the greats before US
helped us get to a certain level and
then you know Michael and Larry and
magic and dust took it to another level
and then the next wave comes Shaq and
Kobe and these guys take it to another
level in the bronze and everyone so it
continues just to rise so you know the
game continue you know you're gonna have
to increase you're gonna have guys
making 50 or 60 million dollars a year
playing basketball yeah I mean so that's
why I'm glad I got you know I got three
more boys I got three chances to hit the
lottery
you know I got three chances so it's
just again it just kind of comes you
know with the evolution of the game so
um you know although we made good money
you know there's guys that are making
more money in one season than we made in
our careers yeah you know so it's it's
the game has evolved I was just gonna
ask like for a contract I'm a little
curious there's a usually a signing
bonus right and then from there
no signing bonuses unconscious to fully
guarantee once we signed every dollar
you hear signing bonuses that's normally
football because their contracts aren't
guaranteed beside behind that besides
that money they get so you'll see a huge
signing bonus and those you'll see a big
deal first of all every deal you see for
professional athlete you could probably
cut it in half because of taxes oh yeah
yeah and then agents and lawyers getting
a bunch of fees so cut it in half and
then after that is where you kind of you
know see what else is going on with your
money but yeah it's not it's not
necessarily the level that everyone may
think it's at
um but again it's still it's still good
money all guaranteed every player in the
NBA show even if they come in on a
10-day contract they guarantee for those
10 days and even if they get injured if
something happens my whole thing is I
you know I signed a three-year deal
um
you know and I ended up winning a
championship the first year of my
three-year deal
the first year of my three year deal I
won a championship and ended up retiring
and I still got paid for the next you
know two years I wasn't even playing and
I was being paid because that's you know
that's the the one great thing about the
NBA is the money is guaranteed what is
it just like a massive bi-weekly check
uh every two weeks twice a month first
in the 15th
that's pretty cool so you got but you
got guys like Kobe that was making 30
million a year and he was getting 15 one
check at the beginning and one check at
the end of the season really so he was
just accepting one check of 15 million
dollars that's crazy imagine that
check on my 15th like I feel like I
would be like putting it into the the
machine in my hand would just be shaking
crazy and are there institutions or
programs within the NBA to ensure that
now people aren't going broke because
it's a thing I mean everyone knows it's
a thing I mean again yeah there's I mean
there's again there's there's things
that are in place
um to make sure guys don't and I think
again
this is new so I'd probably say like the
talk of financial literacy in it really
being cool is probably starting in the
professional ranks probably started
around 2014 1516 in that space where a
locker rooms are talking about you know
what you're investing in or have you
seen this or have you seen that and that
never used to be the talk in the locker
room so
um
you know this is it's newer so and
there's more money now so although guys
are you know blowing money fast I just
think there's money to come and then
there's more responsibility around
teaching guys how to save your money and
invest in your money into the
conversation now so I don't expect to
see this new generation of whether it be
entrepreneurs athletes entertainers
essentially having the same struggles as
you know people before did because again
the conversation there was never
conversation you guys have a poll
podcast on financial literacy pretty
much you know what I mean this is new
you know I mean so the fact that it's
cool and okay to listen to and okay to
follow and you have great people who
have experience teaching you the game
it's less likely that you're gonna [ __ ]
up but some people still do yeah what do
you think of college athletes getting
paid right but I also think there needs
to be something in place for for at the
educational side of it you know what I
mean again most likely they're coming
from nothing I mean these are scholar
athletes that are you know signing these
nice nil deals but again if guys in the
NBA are going you know crazy with money
imagine you know you're 17 in college or
18 in college and you're getting you
know 50 100 250 000 you know so I just
think there has to be some kind of
education uh behind it and understanding
and you know almost like a safe haven
um you know where kids can go to kind of
learn and invest and and start making
their money work for them because
they're getting you know obviously a leg
up on people in the past because we
didn't get paid until you actually make
it and only one percent of people make
it why do you think it's only recently
that Financial education is taking such
a uh a priority the internet yeah the
internet's more popular now so there's
probably always been people probably
talking about it but it just wasn't a
big deal you know now but it's out there
and you can see it on social media
platforms and again it's just a a cooler
conversation you know saving money is
cool now investing is cool now it was
like I said that was never anything
talked about when we came in the game in
the late 90s and early 2000s yeah I feel
like it's an itch that everyone has you
always want to know how much someone's
making how much money they have it's
just like something that's just so
fascinating to everybody but for some
reason it was just taboo for such a long
time I just saw a thing today on
Instagram as we were driving over here
like the top earning athletes and LeBron
was number one and I think he's making
like 43 million from basketball and like
80 million in endorsements
you know what I mean in one year you
know what I mean so it's just like it's
out there and guys are doing it and and
I love to see it because that means you
know it's giving people who are coming
up the aspirational oh [ __ ] if he can
get it I can get it you know so I think
it's cool yeah I think endorsements and
Investments are starting to make up a
lot more money absolutely yeah it's just
so fascinating to know that people could
be making so much money like you said
like it just still blows my mind but in
the summer they'd be they have no money
because like you think like I said every
if you see a contract or or he's making
this much a year you cut it you know
it's we're getting at least 45 is taken
after taxes fees all that kind of stuff
and then once you get that money you
know what are you gonna do with this so
like you see these huge you know pretty
much a 200 million dollar deal it's like
what are you guys going to clear after
that like 100 maybe 100 million 110
million you know what I mean and then
there's all kinds of fees and people
you're paying and the lifestyle and so
it's not although it sounds like that is
a lot of money that was maybe an extreme
example but you know you see like a five
million dollar contract oh and then
you're well they say you're making five
million so some people feel like I need
to leave you know live like I'm making
that much so you're living above your
means so
it's just a gamble with everybody is
different and what do you guys think
because I I heard rumor that LeBron
wants to create a new team here here in
Las Vegas
it's gonna happen well I mean we've been
hearing about it I mean the NBA knows 9
out of 10 times Ron want to be involved
in the team going anywhere in the world
it's gonna happen I feel like it would
immediately just be the most popular I
would ever I think it would be hard to
compete with you're gonna be I mean you
need to be good you know I'm I'm a
California sports fan so I'm you know
I'm a Raider fan I'm a Niner fan but I'm
a Raider fan too and you guys gotta win
although you know people are great and
they want to see you know you want to be
entertained you still got to have a good
product out there I was the first time
hearing that I like all Californians
yeah no question so the Raiders out you
can't be fans of both are you gonna tell
me what I can and can't do what are you
doing wrong 49ers but I like teams from
California you don't like that okay so
he's a Cowboy fan so he doesn't have no
one else if he gets salty all the time
right now they're gonna lose to the
Eagles this weekend I'm sure she's going
to go we're three and two but we're
coming we're on the way
we're on the way huh uh so why do so
many athletes careers only end after a
few years how competitive is it to stay
in it's very competitive because you got
to think it's somebody always trying to
come take your job always somebody
coming in you guys hungrier
I wouldn't say hungrier I think that's
what keeps people uses the hunger that's
what kept us 14. yeah there's just
always you know it's like what's next
always someone there's there's young
kids that are watching you guys that
want to I want their spots yeah you know
they're going to come on your spot so I
think that's just that's human nature uh
but it's just tough man that the odds
are like I said there's only 120 430
guys in the league you know what I mean
you know it's just like turn over every
year you're losing 100 plus guys so like
how how can you say how bad do you want
it got some guys that come in and get
that little taste the first three years
the hiding money and they can't handle
it and feel like you know they get
complacent okay I got these three years
I don't care about being under more nah
you got guys like us that happy to be
here trying to play as long as we can
and do you this is maybe the dumbest
question ever but if you win the
Championships you get a bunch of extra
money or is that basically just like you
get a team bonus you get a team bonus
you got to split it between the team you
guys got about what each player yeah you
know like like Jack said you want to
take care of your truck because the
trainers and and guys that help you stay
through they don't really get the
bonuses but yeah I would say on average
probably between 100 and 200 000 extra
yeah you get especially like if your
team wins best record you get more money
you know I'm saying you get more money
like the coach wins uh Coach of the Year
everybody get a little more in a pot how
do you guys invest your money right now
well I'm involved in a cannabis company
Paula I didn't want I don't want to be
tied down into too many things I have a
Men's Grooming line called you for every
man that's in Target a fresh press Juice
company where we have three stores and
we're also online you know called Vibe
Health bar so it's kind of our version
of Starbucks but just with juice and
healthy stuff adding company active
dreamers where you know we make uh
professional sport betting so we make
you know the blanket is the body and the
pillow cases the head Powers flower and
then we have you know the number one
black Flower Company Los Angeles we
serve all the a lot of a-listers a lot
of big a-listers
um Tech obviously Tech is the way you
know so I have some tech Investments I
also have a cannabis investment
um but just kind of learning on the Fly
again like I said yeah learning on the
Fly and and really you know to me the
best way to learn is you know I have a
lot of older people in the space that I
just bother and lean on and
take a look at this you know take a look
at this deal and what do you think what
should I do you know you do that enough
you kind of start learning
um as well so how do you get into the
Cannabis industry and what's that like
right now with the regulation they're
opening it up a little bit how difficult
is that I got lucky
um my best one of my close friends was
the CEO of our company uh Al Harrington
he um was playing for the Denver Nuggets
in 2010 and that's when it became legal
and we were able to get a heads up a
head start before everybody in the
business and uh being in this is 2010 we
made a lot of mistakes we made a lot of
mistakes but we jumped we got ahead of
everybody so to the point now we were
able to
uh I was able to basically be the face
of athletes getting into the Cannabis
space and um you know he's done some
great things as far as um create
generational wealth for different people
as far as getting to teach people how to
get a licenses uh in the Cannabis space
and how to and how to create your own
business and generation well he's been a
good teacher in the Cannabis space and
um being able like I said being able to
be in the space first in 2010 gave us a
uh up on everybody yeah and uh we was
able to learn the game early to be able
to be where we have our own dispensary
of our dispenser in Detroit and um and
we have different
um
grow houses and uh about uh flower and
different uh cannabis uh dispensaries
all across the country yeah now I heard
uh it's difficult to collect money and a
lot of credit cash businesses cash
business just cash basically I've also
heard stories that you're not supposed
to keep too much cash because it could
be rated or robbed or so how do you how
do you balance the two well I mean
that's a question that I would have to
answer um I just kissed the brown bear
yeah I get the brown paper bags you know
I'm saying I I would have to answer
those questions but
um
he he is basically the guy if you have
if you besides Matt but it's a lot of
guys that's in a cannabis space for
sport wise I'm pretty sure a good 90 of
those guys that went to Al and got game
and on how to move and how to get into
this business I'm just curious if you
guys could maybe say like like what
percentage of your income comes from
different sources I want to know like
how your business is broken down as far
as income goes I would say probably the
largest
amount of money I'm making this from our
podcast
um second is ESPN
um and then outside of that Investments
probably start coming in but you know
multiple you know when you're doing
startups and other stuff you normally
roll that right back into the business
so there's not a ton of money yet coming
from Investments and then I mean through
this podcast I've been able to do a
whole bunch of other stuff as far as
hosting and working for other teams and
a bunch of different stuff so like kind
of miscellaneous would probably round
out where the rest of it comes from easy
easy this show this show is
80 for me really yeah yeah because
um with the with the money from Viola my
cannabis company I don't touch yeah it
goes back into the business yeah sure
and uh the money I saved you know I use
that just to make sure my kids are
straight and families straightened to
live but this show is basically all I do
you know I do speaking engagements every
now and then I do a little stuff to make
money but this is really all I do all I
really want to do I had no idea the
podcast was uh was doing these big
numbers
well I think what was able to help us
was you know our obviously of our
partners Showtime but the first time
around we kind of hit us all in
negotiations with our first deal so I
kind of went out and learned the space
and and kind of started talking to other
companies and in the midst of that you
know really liked I heart at the time
and then you know obviously my loyalty
was to show time so when Showtime came
back around and you know they started
making more sense with what they were
talking about I was just like well how
can we marry the two I heard can I
handle your audio and Showtime can
handle the digital side so we were able
to pretty much get
double because now we're you know we
weren't just before we were just getting
Showtime money now we're just getting
anything from I heart which you know so
they pay you directly and you they
basically have licensing over all of the
content so they have yeah so no so they
have I heart does the audio side of it
and Showtime does the digital side of it
but there I mean obviously it's a
partnership but we get two different
checks from two different companies now
when before we were just getting one how
do you approach that is that before you
started and you said hey we're about to
start this podcast do you want in on it
no I just learned I mean again we this
whole podcast came together randomly
just with you know people you know a
friend connecting us with showtime and
and we found lightning in the bottle so
obviously our first year we you know we
didn't make very much at all but in our
first year we won Sports podcast of the
year so we knew coming into year two I
was like are we getting money this year
so when you know initially when again
the talks had stalled I was just like
okay well damn that's what I'm doing
over here but if they're not gonna pay
us we need to go find someone who's
gonna pay us so again I was talking to
Spotify Apple Amazon I heart you name
and I was talking all these different
companies and then when Showtime's like
okay you know let's make this happen I'm
just like okay you know my loyalties to
you but I also really love what they
have and what they told me over here
like how can we make these work and
since one was primarily audio and then
Showtime is more of a visual company we
were able to you know be partners with
both wow how many followers did you have
at the time when you did that deal well
I know we started with Showtime
basketball I want to say there was a
couple thousand and now we're over seven
hundred thousand yeah uh subscribers on
Showtime uh you
so you know it's it's and obviously
there's other shows but I you know with
all due respect I think we're kind of
the driving force behind you know kind
of getting that wheel rolling and you
know and then now it's helping us and
everyone that's incredible what do you
think of Joe Rogan selling to uh to
Spotify 100 million I think it was but I
mean you know when you listen you listen
to people some people say he under you
know he should have got more I think I
think though he was one of the first to
get such a deal at that caliber and when
he negotiated that like you're already
getting the top so there's there's no
one had McAfee too got a nice job call
her daddy with 50 million bucks
[Music]
yeah it's looking back at that level is
set people don't like accept that you
can negotiate at that level but if
someone had you know done a 100 million
dollar deal before him he's the biggest
yeah he could have done 152. a lot of
those people own 100 of their IP too
I think the day they announced they
signed him I think their stock went up
by like a billion dollars it was
something nuts so when you take his
value to Spotify
some people said like he should have got
more yeah you know what I mean because
he is he is a movement himself
um so you know he's definitely you know
a Pioneer in this space and I haven't
seen an episode but I know he the man in
the podcast
he's got he's got you aspire to us you
know to get to a level like that where
you know you could be set for life
financially from a podcast or whatever
thought that yeah so what's your plan to
continue growing the podcast I have
shows yeah live show just creativity you
know I think I was talking to our team
because we just started season four and
I was just like I feel like we set the
bar in this Sports space although we
weren't the first we set the bar and I
feel like not that everyone's caught up
but now they're in the same they're on
they're in the same book you know so how
this that you know season four how do we
make it to another level
um obviously more fan engagement more
live experiences more you know access to
us we're traveling around doing a lot
you know we're here right now sitting
with you guys and we're you know we're
doing NASCAR and Bubba Wallace this
weekend
thanks to our friends over at moneyline
Ty Gibbs shout out to moneyline number
they make the dreams happen but you know
we got to partner in money line but just
continuing to try to you know give the
fans what they want you know obviously
we feel like you know we're the core of
our show but being able to get top name
guests is important too uh so we
continue to to try to do that but you
know like Jack said live shows merch uh
more fan engagement
um animated we have an animated series
coming we have a cannabis line coming
yeah
um so just continuing to just you know
not just touch this space but you know
how does this you know how does this
cover our entire ecosystem and just be
able to find different streams of
Revenue in different spaces through one
thing yeah I do the commentating and uh
with boxing now so you know it's a lot
of stuff that's that's building from our
podcast that we're taking advantage of
yeah so it's been a blessing yeah so I
got a question if you guys could draw a
pie with three different pieces of the
pie one is the environment in which
people grow up in one is hard work and
one is natural skill how would you draw
the percentages as far as if you want to
be the best that you can be in the NBA
how big each slice of the pie occupy
natural skill is the whole thing to me I
don't agree with that but go ahead and
do your pie first I'm not gonna eat your
piece I'm gonna say natural skill for
what percentage all of it 100 for me
because everybody has a talent and
everybody has a skill everybody don't
feel that figure out what their talent
skills so once I found out my skill was
basketball that's everything to me
because that changed everybody's life
that one game basketball did everything
basketball is the reason why I'm here
are my family's living good why I'm
living good basketball is the source to
all that so having that Talent putting
that all into all together that's the
reason why I'm here without that Talent
I'm not here so you just have one pie no
slices in it I got that pie ate that pie
and I'm gonna make other pies for other
people now just just to play Devil's
Advocate real quick real quick because I
know you want to answer too what about
like you know The Ball Brothers or uh
you know the son of uh Lebron James and
stuff like that or Shaquille O'Neal's
son it's like you know they grew up in
an environment I feel like that culture
played pretty hard into there they still
might not make it they might get to the
NBA they might have might not have a
great career they might they in a
position where their dads can force it
for them so that might help but still
they have to go out there and LeBron
can't go in the game
made when your dad goes away
if you have that skill you can have you
can you can still survive but if you go
away if your dad goes away you don't
have the skill you're gonna be looking
for help
um I would say 10 is the environment I
grew up in
um never letting that hinder me but also
realizing that made me the dog I was and
have the mentality I had and had the
chip on my shoulder I would say 40 is
natural ability I was just a super
athlete when I was younger like
basketball wasn't even my best sport I
was a football player I played baseball
I ran track I'd say 40 is natural
building I'd say 50 is hard work and
there's a lot of guys that are talented
as [ __ ] but don't work you know so where
are they going to go with that
interesting I agree I feel like you know
obviously natural time you have to have
natural Talent you know what I mean like
you have to have some talent but I mean
what are you gonna do I remember Kobe
said like what are you gonna do with
that Talent now like how hard are you
gonna work how much do you want it I
feel like some people are very talented
but don't really want it and then you
can tell yeah and for you Graham if
you're answering this as far as success
in Business and Entrepreneurship what
are the pieces you said so you have
innate just like you know you're a smart
person uh or hard work hard work and the
environment that you grow up oh geez I'd
say probably 50 natural skill because
you have to like really be into what
you're doing and like both of you it
seems like you were just yeah you were
born and so that gives you the ability
to work hard which I would say is
probably another 30 and then 20 20 is
the environment but so I think hard work
and and natural ability could could
overrun your environment like it could
out I agree it could outweigh it it
could be 50 so yeah those two right I
agree so that's what I think about you
what do I think uh as far as business
I'd probably say
50 hard work 40 natural skill and then
ten percent that sounds like my pie you
know what you know what's we all got the
same circle around all our pies yeah all
right
there we go
yeah and I want to hear some hot takes
you guys have very you know not much
time right now if you guys were to say
top three athletes to ever exist top
three athletes to ever exist
you know actually let's say like sure to
ever exist yeah let's say yeah for me
I'm going three I'm three right I'm
going Muhammad Ali Serena Williams
Michael Jordan I'm gonna say LeBron
James because I'm a golfer so I say
tiger okay
um I'm Brady Tom Brady number one he's
just in the mix okay so those are all
yeah yeah Graham that's interesting I
was I would say tiger Kobe I don't know
for a third though
um I'll just take the top two for now
what about you jack I would say cliche
but I'll say Bo Jackson oh good call up
there nice I would say Michael Phelps
and I would say uh Michael Jordan and
you got to think too I mean you think
like Bo Jackson professional athlete in
two Real Sports any parting thoughts
that you want to mention before we wrap
up any advice to people watching any
final thoughts that you want to get out
there messages no question is a dumb
question okay
this is without no question it's a dumb
question you don't know something don't
be afraid to ask I learned that as I got
older and one thing about me I never
listened to reply listen to understand
what you've been told that's interesting
I mean if you wanted you got to work for
it I think at the end of the day I think
you know everyone sees the end product
and thinks oh [ __ ] it should be easy but
you know gets in the grind and they're
not cut out for the grind so whatever
you you know you're gonna get it get out
whatever you put into it
um you know people have to be serious
about their craft and if you love it you
got to put your all into it and manifest
it and believe it and and and
every day you can get better at it oh
thank you guys so much thanks for having
us man thanks for having us man thanks
for having us bro thanks for having us
bro all right until next time you guys
thanks for watching until next time uh
before I forget I gotta get it